en algún lugar de la frontera entre
Polonia Y belarus estos activistas
rastrean el bosque En búsqueda de
migrantes que les hayan pedido ayuda
intentan llegar a Europa a través de
Rusia y velarús les voy a pedir que
digan delante de la cámara que quieren
asilo en Polonia estará en los
documentos
necesito asilo Polonia después de pasar
25 días en el bosque con la esperanza de
llegar a Europa occidental al final
decidieron pedir asilo en Polonia
llevamos cuatro días sin comer solo agua
agua sucia no podemos volver a Marruecos
y tampoco a belarus solo a Polonia
toca pulsar a pesar del muro de 186
kilómetros terminado el verano pasado y
de las patrullas constantes la situación
en la frontera sigue siendo muy tensa
Polonia acusa abelarús de fomentar el
flujo de inmigrantes
estamos asistiendo a la intensificación
de este tipo de actividades le interesa
desestabilizar y mantener la presión
migratoria en esta frontera hay muchos
intentos y últimamente las cifras sean
disparado hasta 200 al día
este año han cruzado la frontera a
15.200 migrantes casi el equivalente a
la cifra de todo 2022 según los
activistas el muro representa más un
peligro que un obstáculo en cuanto el
número de pasos no ha cambiado mucho
sigue pasando mucha gente la diferencia
es que desde que se construye Este muro
hemos tenido muchos heridos piernas
rotas esguinces
de la llegada del grupo Wagner avelarus
y con la Cumbre de la otan como telón de
fondo en la vecina lituania Polonia
refuerza la seguridad en sus fronteras
migrantes marroquíes son conducidos al
puesto fronterizo si Polonia les niega
el asilo serán deportados